[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
welcome to the 2019 spring chess classic
hey we're just coming right on in no
intro today folks my name is Ben Simon
alongside Grandmaster Romana Hambleton
and you caught us in the midst of a very
positive conversation about today's
round and Steve stone-cold fast yeah we
were talking about Stone Cold Steve
Austin well welcome in it's like you're
right here with us today we are 100%
public and we want you to join us in the
YouTube chat we have that open already
and we are just so excited because we
still have a six-way log jam in Group A
so let's kick it off with those
standings now yesterday all drawers and
that's the first time this has happened
in this tournament weeds a lot of we see
a lot of dynamic play we see a lot of
dynamic results yesterday though was a
different story and the cool thing about
today is that all six of those
frontrunners are playing each other
ahman what is your take on group a thus
far well I think the potential of the
log jam continuing remains intact
because if we imagine those three games
being drawn there you go those players
extend the the six six way tie on top of
the table up to three and a half points
so we'll see if that happens today but
it's obviously very very interesting to
see over a couple rounds the same
players being tied atop the table
there's just nothing to come between any
of these players so far and we'll see if
the players who are in the bottom of the
table can turn their tournaments around
because in a strong tournament like this
very high average rating no easy games I
get the feeling that once you sort of
you know establish yourself at the
bottom of that table it's so hard to dig
yourself out you lose confidence and you
know everyone starts to sort of smell
blood and start to pick on you so we'll
see if those guys at the bottom of the
table can reroute their tournaments very
well and let's glance over at our
challengers Division Group B where it's
a different story indeed as the Chinese
Grandmaster by Jin she is in clear first
and we mean clear one and a half points
against up against the three
second-place players what percentage
going from here on out what percentage
would you give by Jin she
as finishing in first place now clear
first clear first yes I 80 percent I
think 80 is you know that's a minimalist
approach to to the thigh James she by
the way
he won his yesterday game and that game
looked like it might have been a draw
against Nicholas Theodore but he somehow
managed to pull off a win as we left
that game at the end of the broadcast it
looked dead wrong so very impressive I
expected
only a one-point lead today but one and
a half points he's really he's really
starting to take off from the rest of
the pack here if you're just joining us
for the first date welcome let's take a
look at the format and introduce you to
what these players are going up against
remember this is a two two fields 10
player round robins time control game in
90 minutes for the first 40 move the
second time control kicks in and adds 30
minutes on it move 41 and then there is
a 30-second increment from the very
first move the players have to take
notation the entire game of course and
we will not see many games and on the
clock there is a 30 move draw rule in
effect which means that the players
cannot offer or agree to a draw before
Black's 30th move has been played and
like I said before be sure to join us
all across social media with on YouTube
with the chat and also at hashtag Spring
chess classic we are on Facebook as well
by the way so hello to you Facebook
viewers remember us chess champs calm is
where you're going to want to go to see
these games on the digital board so
follow along at us chess champs calm and
speaking of that every day at 1:00 p.m.
those games are underway and every day
at 3:30 p.m. is whenever we come on the
air with you the last day is a little
bit different because the last day we
will have playoffs if necessary the last
day is Sunday mark that down clear your
schedule because if we have playoffs
especially you're gonna want to be here
with us absolutely no better place to be
the games are going on right now
upstairs two floors up let's take a look
at the pairings for Group A today
Rustom chasm genre versus varoujan a
Cobian Vasily Ivanovich amman Bach ray
Robson versus Erik Hansen alien is Nick
versus Ari ontari and our key matchup
Jeffrey Zhang versus liam lee it's
important to note though as i said
earlier that all six frontrunners that
stand at three points are playing each
other today so really there could be
three key matchups today we're going
with this one because well the highest
rated players are in it so let's glance
at Zhang versus Lee what's going on in
this game so far Amon
well we have Jeffrey Zhang here as you
mentioned leading the tournament along
with five other friends of his and we
have this position here that's opening
up a pretty significant I want to say
time advantage for for Jeffrey just just
to start off now look Longley am is we
we maybe just go back a little bit in
this game he's in a position here that
offhand doesn't look very good he's got
these disconnected pawns especially that
pawn on d4 is very loose and that Queen
I mean I'm having nightmares that it's
just gonna get trapped in there somehow
as you've got ideas like rook to f6
coming in and you know that Queen is
running out of squares but how did we
get here how did Luke Wong end up in a
position like this against Geoffrey well
we have this very standard idea of
throwing out the check in this opening
and why does black do that because if
white plays Bishop d2 he says okay I
wanted to play Bishop e7 anyway and your
Bishop on d2 well maybe it's not that
well place a lot of times what white
would do if black just played here is
later on he would put his Bishop on b2
if he wants to do that now he's gonna
have to spend that one extra move so you
sort of force him to commit that Bishop
to the c1 h6 diagonal which you know
restricts his flexibility in development
so we see the Catalan position
developing and believe me there is a lot
of theory a lot of games played in this
line so this is very explored territory
for these players right here in h4
played by Geoffrey because a lot of
times what you'll see not necessarily
right away but one of the main ideas is
a move like g5 now it doesn't have to
happen right here but that idea of g5
Kix this bishop away in the end you can
also kick that night away you can get
the F pawn off the board so something
you know as as insane it's just G 5f5
pawn storm on the Kings side it's
actually one of the main ideas in this
opening so Geoffrey's actually taken the
approach of nope you're not doing that
today
no g5 for you takes away one of the the
main plans for black and in exchange
though he does move upon near his King
and sort of does ways to move there but
H for defense g5 and that does give the
King some extra breathing room h6
renewing the threat and we do see laQuan
playing very similar to how Louis
happened there the 94 night when c4 okay
right I mean I didn't see that I'll do
it again in slow motion
thank you actually I think I can do slow
motion like this
no okay 95 takes takes and we have a
very interesting position where now if
I'm honest I wish that I could grab that
pawn and age for it put it right back on
h2 if I could
if this pawn we're here I think white
would be a lot happier it may actually
be a target and some lines and also if
you ever want to play f3 to to hit this
pawn here again you might wish your
pawns back on h2 because it just
supports this g3 pawn it might be a
little bit weaker now but again I think
white is doing well here in this
position based on the bishops look at
that guy on c8 he's not happy it's gonna
take a long time for that bishop to ever
develop over here and White's gonna
break with that three and seems to be a
good position for Geoffrey it you said
that h4 looks to be a target
is it worth considering Bishop takes h4
straight away giving up the bishop for
two pawns well the problem with that
move is that I need more firepower so if
I do this we could say great my Queens
out there I've got a nice rook looking
here but what about these two pieces
they're just not participating and it's
nearly impossible for you know a queen
and a rook to checkmate a king in the
middle of the middle of the game where
you have two bishops of rope near the
white cans just all these defenders so
something
he has to be careful of but I don't
think anytime soon because you got to
get those pieces up for black before
you're making any serious threats so f3
was played to break the pawn Center and
what we actually saw here was basically
the I mean the qualms got a solid center
here but he's got that Bishop that is
gonna be a real issue so moving forward
here he actually decides to give up the
pawn he doesn't want to take here maybe
white takes back starts to push those
pawns up the board he elects to give
that pawn up momentarily and go after
the C pawn instead now I don't know
about the the calculations here on these
moves because it seems to me offhand
like black is playing very very loose
allowing this pawn in the center to be
captured white actually takes a second
pawn on b7 so very temporarily up pawn
here but they are actually tripled on
the e-file so it can't be too proud of
those but it's it's how Geoffrey plays
after that I think is the real the real
boost to his position it's not about
that extra pawn it's about the time
black has to take time to take these
pawns back white says ok I'm gonna
double on the F file I've got my Queen
on the seventh rank and all of a sudden
we see some serious threats to the black
King here as White's Center is has
collapsed but blacks king is the one
that's under fire so I'm very curious
how this position develops here as it
seems to me like look long this has
trouble actually making moves here we
see white finding time for Musa King h3
Bishop e2 in this position rook f7 I
mean it seems to me like you know you
see laQuan shuffling the rook they're
making moves like a 5 Geoffrey seems to
be in command in this position here so
as we reach the current position I
believe we're sitting here after we
moved Bishop e8 rookie 700k I was
wondering why the Queen just didn't take
the d4 pawn now I see because the bishop
moves to e8 this got her attack on the
rook already so that's why here that
move would be well met by simply Bishop
e8 taking the rook so he played Queen c5
there should be eight rookie 7 and this
pawn is something to worry about for
Geoffrey but honestly these pieces have
a real hard time entering
gain rook b8 will always be met by let's
at e3 if I just want to protect
everything and in the meantime I've got
pieces joining the attack and long term
I think I said initially I'm worried
about that Queen you do run out of
squares if you're not careful here
alright well that's where we stand right
now with Geoffrey Zhang and Liam Lee
let's take a look over at Group B and
the pairings going on in that division
stein crimson versus CAD rich korilla
versus me stop Qaeda nob versus Arenberg
barged pullets versus the Adaro and our
key matchup in Group B is by ginchy
versus Alexey Sorokin this is a
first-time matchup and it's a chance for
bhaijan she just to simply increase his
lead against the bottom seed so big day
for him I don't know if I can say it'll
be an easy point but let's see where
just by the numbers Ivan no no insult to
Sorokin intended but where do we stand
in this game ya know that that's the
thing with these these tournaments and
why I think all the players like these
tournaments hosted at the st. Louis s
Club is because you always feel like you
can beat anyone in the field and
likewise for pi genchi I'm sure that he
feels he can also lose to anyone in this
field so you know you got an F M rated
over 2,500 that's almost scarier than
facing a GM back that guys uh you know
you gotta be careful of those guys
what's this guy up to unknown exactly
what's his motive motif so Alexei
Sorokin here is playing with the black
pieces and once again this is a type of
position that I sort of classify as one
of those positions you can grind try to
win but I don't feel like you ever risk
losing from bhaijan cheese perspective
here so he's got the pawns out of the
way you know this bishops not causing
any problem you have this long-term idea
of maybe bringing the king all the way
in this pawn here if you leave it for
k-6
all of a sudden I might just take that
pawn and c4 is an idea that actually
kicks the bishop out and we actually see
them with c4 plate on the board that's
pretty much an automatic that Bishop is
so nicely anchored there on d5 you want
to disrupt the harmony in blacks
position and say okay you got to move
your bishop now
if you go to e4 then you know maybe you
give me a tempo on my King taking a jog
up the board you also block the e-file
for your pieces to use and the nice
thing is if we just imagine this
position because I do have to watch this
pawn so probably will play fish before
White's got control of the only to open
files that are really workable here and
the other open file black is blocking
with his own bishop so whites really got
full control in this position now is the
OP material no or is he threatening to
win material not exactly but I think
that long term he's just got all the
pressure in the position you've got
ideas of moving your King up you've got
a bishop that's not actually doing
anything so you could try to use that
piece whether it's to h3 whether it's
trading off this Bishop I think at the
end of a lot of lines here white as a
potential to be up upon in an endgame
and may be Sorokin can can still draw
that position but I think he's gonna
have to work hard here and bhaijan she
has demonstrated a lot of confidence
when he's playing in these types of
positions where he almost feel like he
can't lose and he's turned a lot of
positions that have been dead draws if
we remember in this tournament
he played Gregory kadanoff in that equal
pawn Knight endgame turned it into a win
pretty effortlessly he also had that
game against Nicholas Theodore ooh in
the last round Bishop and gain equal
pawns symmetrical just like the Cardinal
game turned it into a win so again we
have a position equal pawns symmetrical
he's gonna turn it into a win again I
don't know Ben but by June she's
definitely making a case that these
slight advantages comfortable positions
are his wheelhouse and look for him to
try to push this for win today I really
want to get that C pawn off the board
the black C pawn what about a move like
okay let's try trading the bishops off
Bishop g2 is it possible and then we
trade the bishops off and then we can
pick up that pawn on c6 right absolutely
no Bishop g2 is a move you definitely
consider here the only reason he's
probably spending some time is you
always wonder in positions where you
know you're a bit better where do i cash
in you know what's my best what's my
best cash in right here is is it trading
the bishops winning that pawn or is it
actually more annoying for me to leave
the bishops on the board
maybe pressure a bit more trade them
later you have to decide whether
Black has anyways out and maybe you want
to keep that pressure for now or do it
later
but if we imagine that this gets played
you're absolutely right you're gonna win
one of these pawns and this was the type
of position I was talking about where
maybe Black has the hope to give up one
pawn and get his rook active play a rook
endgame we were down upon but we all
know that those have very good drawing
chances so something like in this
position he could play okay probably not
c5 let's go rookie seven activity you
never wanted to sit there defending in a
Brooklyn game so let's say he does take
this the rook gets down and this is an
example of how that activity immediately
pays off black gets a pawn back and
survives the same game so you got to be
careful when you play those moves like
Bishop g2 that you don't just give your
opponent all this activity for nothing
so I think he wants to put the grips on
the stranglehold on the position and
then look to cash in a little bit later
well another thing he might be looking
at the end this variation on the rook
aiming for the a4 pawn but if we go back
to where we were I suppose it's the live
position yes this is the live position
Bishop e4 okay okay so if Bishop u2 I
can black just play Bishop c2 and go
after the a4 pawn and yep we're just
even well Bishop c2 is gonna be well met
by Bishop takes pawn here and
unfortunately I get to two things at
once I au upon I defend my pawn really
everything in my favor there so it's
actually in blacks interest to go for
the line that we were just talking about
where you trade the piece as much as
possible go for that pure rook endgame
because the presence of bishops on the
board is actually what makes this
position so good for white that's kind
of why I don't want to trade the bishops
off right away I feel like that's
actually the key to why it's advantage
so I would be looking for and no doubt
by June she's also considering ways to
keep that Bishop on the board apply the
pressure maybe improve his King improve
his pawns you know he sort of seems like
he has time to work blacks a little bit
tied up defending this pawn defending
this pawn bishop in the middle of the
board maybe later on you can trade those
bishops but it seems like he can make
some small improvements first and then
trade later very well you know these
players are going to edit for a lot of
money on the line
for a tournament like this let's take a
look at our prize funds first in Group A
twenty-two thousand dollars total on the
line and the champion leaves with six
grand and Group B is very generous as
well fourteen thousand dollars total put
up by the st. Louis chess club first
place the champ leaves with four grand
okay so now that we've Lance at our key
matchups on paper let's look at some
more key matchups and I know Eric Hanson
has played a stunning sacrifice a knight
G to move just seemingly giving up the
night we've got to take a look at this
game ya know that this game looks like
one too to focus on as well as the fact
that this is matchup between leaders we
mentioned we have so many potential key
matchups today been three of us because
we got a six way tie and you know as
fate would have it they're all playing
each other which is fantastic for
today's round I was mentioning before
the broadcast that we don't have any
games finished and that's because these
games are all so tense they're all
between leaders Eric Hanson playing with
the black pieces against Ray Robson and
let's just jump back a little bit so we
can see exactly what happened and why
White's King side seems to just
disappeared from the board here Ben
Knight g3 was played by Ray's we see
just back up a little bit to show you
guys this is a pretty standard position
that you might get from root Lopes
you'll see both players actually going
for this typical maneuver of bringing
the two knights over here black just
Knight came like that and white tonight
came like that so d5 was played d4 was
played and both players immediately get
rid of the center pawns and then that
means since it was Eric's turn to move
he said okay I'm gonna start rerouting
all my pieces over here and we can see
everything sort of aiming at that King
side Bishop C - what's that bishop doing
on a four now absolutely nothing so it's
getting right back into the action Queen
f6 Knight g3 and hello Knight takes G to
plate now we have to see exactly what we
will be make of this move whether it's a
very good move whether it's a
speculative sack
we'll have to see Ray's treatment was
okay
take it that's a no brainer can't let
that night go to g2 and just you know
reach his hand in the cookie jar take
that pawn jump though not happening well
this is gonna be one heck of a sacrifice
the only reason you're moving your
knight to g2 is to simply attract the
King to g2 he's got to have a lot of
firepower here yeah Knight h4 played
King h1 now why did the king go to h1 I
believe that the move King g1 you'd be
faced with all sorts of firepower here
with bishop takes d4 that Knight comes
in to f3 we do lose that rook on e 1 and
at the end of the day there's also
Bishop takes h3 to consider so there's a
lot of things that actually concern me
here with White's position he decided
king h1 he says you can have this pawn
on f2 and why did he do that because he
intensively rook g1 and trade Queens he
thinks that if he gets the Queen's off
the board you know that the resulting
position is going to be maybe three
pawns for the piece but those are very
imbalanced positions the problem for
Eric is that once the Queen's were
forced off the board he was able to play
queen g1 Knight f3 so might say oh wow
you know Queens off the board no more
attack but what Eric was able to do here
is create as worth noting that the
knight cannot take the knight on f3 in
that position because there's a
absolutely pin yep no that's a great
point Eric doesn't have to play this if
you had to play this what we'd be
looking at three pawns for the piece
that's you know when there's a middle
game there's still 4 minor pieces on the
board for white you got to be careful of
positions like that I think that white
actually or whoever has the extra piece
in that case has a lot to play for
probably winning if you get to an end
game with three pawns for the piece then
maybe the three pawns are more valuable
in this case though there was no way
seemingly for a to just exchange the
Queens very nice tactic here Queen takes
g1 King g1 and it's been pointed out
Knight f3 some sort of incredible move
that you can't take because this knight
is pinned to the king and black is going
to reclaim that Queen on d2 and then in
this position I think we did have a move
and this is our up-to-date position rook
to h1 played the time is about even for
these players 16 minutes apiece
and a wild position Eric has three ponds
and one rook for two nights
now without without thinking much here
that is generally very good for for
black so I would say Eric is better here
now what he has to be careful of and
what Ray is gonna be playing for is the
the activity the compensation the fact
is there are four minor pieces on the
board and there's a black King which has
some threats to deal with if you play g6
looks normal
he's actually gonna be facing maybe some
dark square issues trying to get that
Bishop in 94 threatening Knight f6 so
there's still a lot of play left in this
game then but I think objectively those
three pawns plus the rook for the two
pieces more than enough black should be
very happy with how that sacrifice
turned out but you know practically you
know from a human perspective you can
still make a lot of threats with four
minor pieces on the board for Ray Robson
here to negate the threat of Bishop
takes h7 or work takes h7 straight away
in the current position right would you
recommend an alternative to g6 h6 or
something else well you know all things
considered g6 should not be that bad of
a move because let's not forget we do
have a dark square bishop so it's not
like we're exposing our dark squares
with you know nothing to cover it
there's always the idea that this Bishop
can hopefully reroute however if you
play h6 then you also have to put up
with maybe the idea of a knight coming
in to f5 and now the G file might be
scary if in this position let's imagine
I play the move Knight Knight f5 or
something rook g1 is coming next and
there's more threats right so g6 is nice
because then if you switch the G file
there's no more threat so my pawn on g6
is kind of a rock there but if you play
h6 I'm worried that the play switches to
the G file maybe you have to play g6 as
well and if I'm going to play g6 and h6
then I start to get worried I'm moving
too many pawns in front of the Kings so
maybe the action switches there we
actually see in the game and you have
moves developing he's gone for h6 so
will we see Ray start to operate on the
G file here the good thing for Eric is
that in the event of Knight f5 if you
decides to take it white has to take
with the bishop
if you can't use that night even though
he'd love to and we're gonna see those
like rook da rook e8 very very quickly
so I think this is still very
complicated position but definitely I
gave the edge to - Hanson here with
three let's be honest three connected
pass pawns that haven't moved yet but
they will soon and the closer you get to
an endgame probably the more pieces you
trade off as long as Erik never lets
let's give an example let's say he plays
Bishop takes this is probably not what I
would do right you're giving away the
two bishops and you gave away both your
bishops for two nights in the last two
moves this I don't like but as long as
there keeps a bishop on the board so he
can watch those key squares I think that
long-term this definitely pays off for
for Hanson against Ray Robson as he gets
up from the board there as the players
have about 15 minutes apiece and the
very very interesting sort of imbalance
position ahead as we have two pieces for
rook and three pawns I know you and Eric
are stream quite often and the chess
bras in general has he been streaming
this week we've been streaming a little
bit we've actually had this dream active
as well not necessarily from us but
that's why it's nice to have a team team
behind you to make up the slack because
Eric's been you know he's been busy
focusing on the tournament so we managed
stream a little bit but not as much as
we used to do you think that keeps him
sharp or is it just to unwind and have
some fun or both I think a bit of both
but it's it's also very fair to say that
the opposite may may be the case it you
play too many blitz games you play
players that are a lot weaker maybe than
the ones you're playing in this
tournament that can have the opposite
effect and maybe dull your senses a
little bit so I know you know personally
and I think it's true for Eric as well
that he likes to stay pretty sharp
during these tournaments it doesn't like
to play too many casual games blitz
bullet you know wrap it even just mostly
focus on the games and the players in
the tournament ahead so I think he likes
to stay pretty fresh we've been
streaming and you know that's mostly
just to have fun and sort of relax and
have a diversion from from the term
well that's always good to have be sure
to check out Ches bras on twitch for
more on the chest broad stream let's
glance over at Group B I want to take a
look at I'm gonna look at Gregory que
Donna versus Sergei Arenberg right now
quedan of is one of the players sitting
in second place the time for second
place because we know this is the baigan
shisho but where are we at in this game
oh the actually I got that say that
these two have actually played once
before but it's one of those situations
ancient history the 2005 an Aeroflot
open and Arenberg was victorious same
colors so this is their second meeting
and Arenberg is away from the board no
doubt they you know the players are
obviously have that 2005 game coursing
through their blood right now as the the
revenge is on on the mind of Ehrenberg
here I'm hidin off okay down over lost
yeah I'm sure if we could see his eyes
yeah I neither event yeah you can see
the reflection of this 2005 this doesn't
look like a this doesn't look like a
position that Chi Donna wants out of the
opening Ehrenburg here sitting pretty
with the two bishops but most
importantly you know they can disappear
at any moment Knight takes g6 what I'm
excited about for black is the fact that
this bishop even if there's not a bishop
pair that Bishop is a strongest piece on
the board no question
very very nice pressure on the f2 square
and we have to take a look at Kadena
what has he done with his King side
structure he earlier on in the game
played the move g4 and what that means
is that long term all these dark squares
around the King here been are completely
weak and let's imagine that in this
position Knight takes g6 is played just
to illustrate Queen c2 may be defending
this pawn after move like Queen e5 we've
got ideas like Bishop there Queen comes
down h2 we have moves like Queen f4
hitting that pawn on f2 g5 just fixing
everything
I think this could be like a dark square
clinic on the Kings side
not to mention Ehrenburg with the pawns
over here not only does he have in this
position one extra pawn please also got
the potential for two connected pass
pawns to develop on that Queen side so
this looks like a fantastic position for
Ehrenberg and I think he's just much
better here what's the real concern of
Sergey getting a queen down to h2 if
he's able to stack that Bishop behind it
because it looks like why it's still
gonna be safe move over to f1 and what
damage is done no absolutely this on its
own not enough King goes to f1 and just
like you say white is actually
completely safe there if I combine a few
ideas though then I maybe start to get a
little scared
specifically I would probably start by
targeting f2 and that sort of puts white
in a bit of a bind here we may tie down
the Queen and King to this pawn and I
feel like I need to use my rook as well
as my past pawns here but long-term what
you're gonna have is the idea of well
I've got these Queen side pawns you need
to deal with and I have that Queen h2
idea attacking the King and once I start
to divert your attention on both sides
of the board then long-term I think that
becomes difficult to deal with but
you're definitely right on its own Queen
h2 not enough but we'll see Sergei
Arenberg I think increase the pressure
here as Caetano has to decide is he
gonna take that Bishop on g6 if he
doesn't let's not forget then that these
are the two bishops you're dealing with
here I think black has a comfortable
comfortable edge here all right very
well and this is the live position yes
this is the live board and it's actually
Kodama if you can see him there thinking
you know what is he gonna do is he gonna
play Knight takes g6 get rid of that
bishop because maybe the the idea is
Bishop takes e4 in the current position
so he's got to deal with that one way or
the other
alright I'm glancing at our very active
YouTube chat today
Digby Mooney says is this stream on
twitch it's this one is actually not on
twitch the Spring Classic is only being
sent out to YouTube and Facebook and
another player is asking where can I see
or another viewers asking where can I
see late I said to another player right
that's good he's really a player he
probably is a player yeah if he's
watching the st. Louis
you know he's obviously got that chest
bug the the addiction he's probably
watching the videos and getting in the
chest so that's that's a fair assumption
right right right
true that Michael and Penny a who has
been joining us I think every day I see
is very active he's saying the player
ratings are on the board I'm not too
sure about that but if you want to see
the player ratings check out us chess
champs calm there's a cool little module
there from chess 24-hour video is
embedded right in there it just keep the
chat window open in another tab and
you'll be set to go okay so moving on
any other games are any other games
catching your eyes how about var Akopian
as black against roost M Casa manana
this is a group a action right here var
looks like he is in pretty good shape
too it looks like there's a battle for
the C file is what's going on here yeah
no this this looks like he is probably
he's either dead lost or he's in
fantastic shape
because when you got that night there
he's either pinned right and he's just
losing a night I don't think that's a
bishop lined up with the Queen to right
I don't think that's the case at all or
he's just winning he's got that
connected let's be honest sorry
protected sorry pass pawn on d5 and that
is a that's like a usually a game winner
also pawns on light squares
dark square bishop for white it seemed
like in the last couple moves will just
show the liquidation here after b3
Bishop b5 this is that is a hero beep on
their right we got two connected pawns
on the Queen side one pawn is saying
like nope I mean you guys can't move and
if you can't move those pawns at all
you're facing equally tough position it
actually calls Kasim John over here to
play a for B for exchange and play Queen
takes a three so this was something that
Kasim jenoff decided to go for it that's
why I have to give it an extra thought
because you don't just give up upon for
nothing unless your position is really
that bad so what's his idea here he has
got two pins and vara has to decide how
he's going to deal with this position
offhand it strikes me as you know if
there's no way that the blacks just
losing here it doesn't feel right
far as position looked good the whole
way and it would be crazy to think that
there's
tactic here that just wins however we
can definitely show exactly what Kasim
jonov is thinking so for example one way
to get out of the out of the pin let's
say might be Knight a six so we're
hitting this rook we're also hitting the
Queen there's a few moves here for white
first of all if rook takes maybe I would
just play well and the bishop can't take
cousin it's me right it's not quite me
but I think this is the wrong path for
black because you're you're faced with
this bishop you always got to deal with
Bishop here as a threat and maybe just
rook here and rook down there and just
win that Bishop threaten mate so I think
this is the wrong way to do it but if if
you play rook takes rook here then I
start to thinking and now if you take
the rook I will take this and now this
is fine for black because he lost level
work in that exchange if I play Queen
takes e7 it's also important to remember
first of all this is hanging with check
but a nice trick is that the Brooke
always has that Square to come back to
guarded by the Queen so you never get
back rank mated or anything like that in
in these lines so even here Queen takes
e7 first of all this is an idea but
again I like this rook takes rook e8 and
I think you cover yourself here so I
think for example Knight a6 that's just
the first move that that sort of caught
my eye here but it seems like that
already gets out of the pan safely and
if that's the case we're dealing with
not necessarily miscalculation by Kasim
Jono but just a really tough position
earlier he felt that he needed a sack
upon to get out of it and we'll see if
he can hold the resulting endgame
position because seems to me like based
on initial calculations vara Cobian is
absolutely pressing here and by the way
I find that very impressive he's got his
trademark French defense and it has been
very effective he did actually beat
Yvonne shook in the French earlier in
the tournament and we have this game
where you might be present for the win I
mean the French is not regarded as one
of the the top tier opening choices and
I mean far continues to wield it
very effectively I think that's very
impressive actually whenever varm first
came to st. Louis
before he actually lived here but it was
around here quite often he seemed to be
whipping up everybody's interest in the
French defense and this French defense
became like a st. Louis st. Louis
opening mm-hmm and you come to st. Louis
chess club you're gonna be playing
against the French defense so be aware
of that
be aware okay so Group B what's next
what's next what do we want bar sh
pullets theodoro shall we take a look
sure yeah the Theodore game we have what
is going on here we got a couple kings
with no clothes on very standard looks
like it came from some sort of Kings
Indian of sorts yeah some kind of Kings
Indian position right from the opening
and a bit of this is theory but what we
actually get in the middle game was a
position where I mean both sides are
looking at f4 and f5 usually black is
first in these type of things but why
can it not happen straight away well
because if I take all of a sudden don't
forget that epon he's gonna be a little
loose from all the firepower that
White's building up there so you can't
quite go for f5 but after a couple moves
here black says okay listen you can take
a pawn here oh I just want a free pawn
but in exchange I am going to get that
f5 move happening and then we're just
gonna see a very typical counter play
coming from that Kings Indian defense of
Nicholas Teodoro here a five takes takes
and White's up a pawn but he's really
missing that dark square bishop and the
developing position after f4 really
starts to get exciting here as the
players are down to about 10 minutes
apiece and we see a very common idea
which is f4 you take and no I don't take
right back which would maybe allow the
Knights to come in or something but
instead you just leave that pawn there
and go Bishop to g4 putting a lot of
pressure on these three pieces here you
got the rook hitting the night and you
also got that Queen looking to join the
attack on the diagonal maybe
shuffle the king over and bring a rope
to g8 Black has a lot of long-term
attacking options but again white is up
that one pawn and you know you can't
just force to checkmate to happen it
doesn't work that way you know you said
that f5 shouldn't be played because then
b5 is really weak what has changed about
the situation that allows this for
Nikolas well it's not so much that a 5
is a weak thing in general is just in
the exact position where I mentioned
that there was a bishop sitting here
there was a knight there and there was a
rook here so there was three pieces
adding pressure to e5 what changed was
white played Bishop a3 and then black
played night before and said okay you
can take a pawn but suddenly your
bishops not there your Queen's offside
then it's time for f5 bye bye black so
no e5 is not necessarily weak but it was
just hanging basically so he needed to
to find a way to make that move without
the pawn being hanging and white sort of
gave him that option he moved his Bishop
Black had to give up a pawn for it but
he considered that worth it and now
we're experiencing the compensation here
as black is all-in on this attack rook
takes f4 Knight sinks into e6 very very
annoying usually what happens is this
Knight goes to g3 in these positions if
if needed just a very solid way of
dealing with the King side plugging up
the G file and if black has to take that
night believe me it looks like here
that's a big fork on these two pieces if
he has to take that night and he does in
the current position takes with the rook
why if you took with the bishop I was
just about to say I mean not only is
there Knight takes F for but even
positions where pawn takes I mean these
these light squares are very very weak
here so bargepole it seems to be doing
well
in his position but we will see the
counter play continue to develop as in
the current position after black just
sacrificed the rook he's got to continue
with just as much firepower and with the
rook hanging here I'm wondering how he's
gonna do that I have a feeling that
already this this is just a very very
good position for Andre bars pullets 100
bars pullets the former Group B champion
in our seasonal classic series plays for
Ukraine
I understand we do have a result our
first result of the day in Group B it
was our key matchup as by June she and
Alexi Sorokin have drawn their game it
was a Brook end game we were able to
glance at it a little bit earlier how
did it end right it actually he did
exactly that he did exactly Bishop g2
now the move honestly surprises me a
little bit but maybe he was faced with
the idea of Bishop here and didn't want
to do bishop takes a four because one
thing is true after Bishop g2 I do not
think there's anything to play for he
probably had an even smarter way okay he
played rook here
very similar to what what I was
mentioning that as long as you get
active in those broken games you you're
never too worried about about dropping
material and yeah these guys agree to
withdraw here in a fairly fairly dry
position where black is gonna reclaim
that pawn on c5 both Kings just can't
join the action and dead even materials
so by gen sheet with the white pieces I
mean he's got such a cushion on top of
the tournament he does not need to win
games anymore but he's gonna take his
chances when they come and didn't seem
to be presented with any today so he he
accepts a draw against Sorokin and
maintains his lead in the tournament
just a spectacular performance by by +4
in this event an amazing 5 out of 6 and
we're already saying he's probably gonna
win this thing and we've got three and a
half rounds to go okay so he's a
front-runner for sure right let's hop on
over to Group A and check out helia news
knicks game against ariane tari ukraine
vs. norway and these are two of the
frontrunners in Group A right this is
another matchup between leaders we have
the last move rook C to plate and I see
that big time advantage for an inning
because black hasn't played his 48th
move yet so black is about to hit them
40 get that 30 minutes extra time so
these guys will not be in any time
scrambles but right here it looks like
if anyone's pressing that's got to be
alien is Nick
however these Knights can also be can
also be clumsy Wow
Black's position may look like you know
there's 96 in the position to worry
about
tari has to has to deal with this but at
the same time you know long-term that
palm in h4 is is completely gone so
white is sort of playing the position a
little more tactically he's threatening
96 right now which would win the
exchange on c6 and Atari has has that
move to deal with now if you can deal
with that that H bond is is falling and
maybe black is doing well but I think
this is a very difficult move to face
right now 96 threatening check and the
rook on c6 so what does he do about that
the answers are either get your king out
of check and the only square to do that
is King d8 not usually place I'd love to
put my king here and the other way is
just to protect the rook but I don't see
a way to do that either
maybe rook c5 or King d8 these are the
only moves that that come to mind here
neither of them are moves I really want
to play so maybe there are other moves
but Nanak is getting up from the board
there that I don't think time pressure
is gonna be any part of this game not
for a long time at least and again if
Tory can sort of maintain the the idea
of surviving this one big threat then
like I mentioned 96 or just Bishop takes
h4 our moves on the horizon but I think
Ilya is doing well here because of how
well is king is placed in the middle of
the board that King activity is very
meaningful in the end game and we also
have this pawn advance pretty far up the
board the only thing is that these
Knights sometimes can be a little clumsy
they almost want to jump into the exact
same squares so kind of bumping into
each other but 96 is the biggest threat
I think that King d8 and rook c5 can be
considered if 96 breaking the
communication thankfully Bishop d6
renews that and you do not lose material
but tari has a big threat to deal with
here as he faces 96
ich nicht all right very well we'll keep
an eye on this game another one we
haven't looked at yet in Group B is
Kristian korilla versus Alexander Mistah
gorilla has just offered a queen trade
there even on material it looks like
should black accept a queen trade well I
think the bottom line here is that
gorillas position is not good that's for
sure we have a Frank kiddo tonight and
you do not see that too often for a good
reason the night cannot go to f4 or h4
it looks like a very nice move was
played at some point in fact it was just
played last move g5 s great move and it
just completely dominates this Knight
has nowhere to go long term you have
this bishop arriving at f3 and if that
rook ever gets down here it's just game
over so you got to be really really
careful here if you're if you're korilla
I think the Queen exchange is fine
I think declining a Queen exchange is
fine that black position is probably
going to be good in either case which
one is better here is is the question
queen e7 looks like a very reasonable
move you know keeping the Queen on the
board maybe ideas like Queen out here
now what do you run into with Queen e7
is maybe the idea broke d6 and suddenly
white is saying well I'm actually gonna
pin your knight and this is not so
comfortable for you so there's a there's
a few ways to look at this Queen e7
isn't move I want to play but Queen
takes d4 is also something I think black
can be very comfortable with as I'm
looking forward to the endgame korilla
is saying that I've got this bishop on
c4
it's plugging the C file completely so
Brooke doesn't get in and there's no
other ways an accept the defiled but
thankfully white has got complete
control of that for the moment if the
Queen moved to e7 and then the rook
moved down to d6 as you said could black
play rook to d7 absolutely rook d7 and I
think that I mean although the pawns are
even we have to remember that white does
have these double isolated pawns so I do
prefer black probably in any any
position really any end
any fair trade of pieces so if Brooke
takes then probably black would have to
decide between Queen Bishop takes let's
say he goes Queen takes even in a
position like this I think black is
doing fine but korilla trading all the
pieces maybe he thinks he has chances in
the endgame it's really hard to tell
because you trade too many pieces don't
forget that's an outside passed H pawn
that white just can't match right
there's no way to make a passed on over
here
so I think the end games are bad and I
think you realize going to be doing some
suffering here in this game for sure
he's down on time he's got 10 moves to
make with 3 minutes to play and rook c5
has just been played by me stuff so he's
ok with the Queen trade he just wants it
to be on his terms he didn't want to
deal with rook d6 maybe in this pin so
he's saying look we can trade Queens but
you know it's it's got to be on my terms
alright well we see that Mistah is
definitely in the driver's seat here
yep that's for sure what a game have we
seen yet Yvonne shook and Bach how about
in Group A and I think that's our last
group a game that we have yet to glance
at yeah okay yeah there's this one and
the one thing about this the one thing
about this position is that earlier on
I've just jumped back to the move g5
which I thought was really fun when we
see g5 we know that Black is thinking
about the attack and it's actually
really hard to deal with free von Schuch
who's Queen and Bishop have sort of been
relegated on this side of the board and
it's kind of crazy both of these pieces
are just entirely out of play
look at that Queen look at that bishop
you want to play c4 to you know get that
Bishop on that diagonal makes so much
sense but c4 it seems to always run into
maybe 94 suddenly the Queen joins from
c6 let's not forget that takes on h4 is
a very big move and you can't take that
pawn because Queen h3 arrives very very
quickly on the board and that is not
necessarily checkmate but very close to
it and you don't want your King on the
run like
middle of the game you have to have your
king coming out to f3 I think exactly
now that that doesn't look proper
doesn't look profit that's no good
no so you can probably survive there but
the calculations I mean blacks on the
attack at the very least there's
something like a perpetual here and
again with these pieces not even part of
the game it seems like that that seems
incredibly risky to you to undertake so
if you went Bishop c1 and he said look
you can take that pawn I've got your
rope hanging here and I would say
honestly a nice reroute by Eve on check
your Bishop c1 I didn't like the bishop
on this diagonal because c4 was always
meant by 94 and what it means is that
the bishop joins on e3 nicely and
honestly I do like Ivana exposition if
you can take here create some threats
the bishop is on a much much better
diagonal and square on e3 so it really
comes down to you know Kenna's Queen
finally joined the action from b3
Benjamin Bach has compromised his King
side so much just to get this attack
going with g5 that now if it doesn't pay
off then that's long-term weakness right
where's your Jeep on it's just missing
and White's King is actually
surprisingly safe here so with 30
seconds ticking down what move are we on
26 here move 26 he's got so many moves
to make before time control von Schaack
is strolling around the room while he's
in time pressure so I think Benjamin is
gonna have to play some very very quick
moves here this doesn't look comfortable
for for Bach at all Oh some people out
there might be saying oh you get 30
seconds to move though so you have
plenty of time it's not really one
minute left I mean what would you say to
something somebody like that well it's
kind of crazy the the feeling that you
get when you're in time pressure versus
when you're playing blitz because when
you're playing blitz you get down to a
minute that's a lot of time that's like
a third of your clock and you you have
that confidence and you've been playing
fast the whole game but it's when you
get that pace shift you've been thinking
long and hard every single move of the
game suddenly you have a minute
that's not a third of your clock that's
way way different proportion and you've
been playing so slowly that suddenly
every move you make has to be quick and
it's just that that sudden pace shift
that throws you off and believe me
having one minute in a classical game
somehow just never feel
the same as having a minute in a blitz
game or time scramble because you're
just not used to it you've been sitting
there for you know three four hours
playing slowly and it can be really
nerve-wracking to all of a sudden be
required to play to play immediately
yeah so how are you perceived the time
yeah in that environment okay and our
last game that we will look at for the
first time in Group B as he had in the
stein Grimson versus Denis CAD rich
Iceland versus Bosnia there's a wallet
pause there is Harris is a big wall here
this looks like a Kings Indian if I've
ever seen one been Knight d4 was the
last move we have to do a bit counting
here so what's going on we have a rook
for a knight and pawn is what it looks
like rook for night and upon White has
this you know obviously really nice pawn
chain black does as well
you can anchor that night on the c6
square but I have to feel like Denis
Godrich has this position really in his
favor here because the White King is
always going to be animating net I mean
that's like a permanent thing unless you
sort of run out here staying in the
corner there if you take if you push it
doesn't matter that is a long-term
mating net that you are that you're
stuck in there's no way out of that so
you always got a checkmate on the back
rank to worry about you got this
diagonal which is lethal white is
missing his dark square bishop and that
Bishop on e3 usually or f2 that often
holds the the whole position together
and if I back up a little bit curious to
see where that Bishop went but it looks
to me like this pawn structure sort of
compromised that that that Bishop yeah
it was here he actually played Bishop b6
voluntarily took here now he actually
won upon as a result of that but we can
see the resulting position that rook
running out of squares he didn't even
have have time to play rook back there
would be rook takes b5 to pieces for the
rook
so actually his whole idea of Bishop to
b6 I think it fell flat on his face
because you never want to give up that
bishop although he did went upon he had
to give up his rook for a night right
after and then the resulting position I
think this is all CAD rich here as
I think CAD Raj has been he's had a few
losses in this tournament maybe in a row
I'm not sure but I seem to remember him
having a few tough games recently and so
he is looking at bounce-back was
potentially a win here against hidden
Stein Crimson as players down to about
six minutes and I think this is all in
blacks favor he just played the move
Knight a seven there's no entry into the
Kings side for white so you know
everything is just on the queenside
Black's got the the rook swinging over
and I mean this pawn is hanging here and
like I said you got to watch out for
Queen a7 on that diagonal the a file the
C file the B file as soon as that pawn
is captured I think this is all CAD rich
here as he definitely has the advantage
here looking to push for a win our the
night on the e6 and the bishop on f8
just kind of met for each other neither
is ever going to move again or be
liquidated off the board does ketteridge
want to improve the bishop what's going
on yeah I think CAD rich wants to
improve the bishop because you can
always play Bishop e7 which contributes
to guarding this pawn guarding that pawn
and just getting off the square in case
white ever wants to take you I don't
think either player is like black would
be would love to have that trade Y that
night on e6 is White's best piece I mean
there's there's no question there so I
think that that blacks not worried about
ninety xf8 but at the same time if
anyone can improve their pieces imagine
that black gets that Bishop to b6 just
imagine that would be amazing that
Bishop on this diagonal is extremely
dangerous
and don't forget black can switch to the
attack at literally any time and just
play the movie h3 if he swings the rook
over here and gets that Queen over I
mean h3 and suddenly White's getting
made it all over again so I wouldn't be
surprised if white actually plays the
move h3 himself pretty soon just to get
rid of that threat but this Knight is
White's best piece he never wants to
trade it black can maybe try to improve
the bishop but again that's a scenario
that's in Black's favor where he's not
worried about the exchange and he's the
one who can improve his minor piece that
and I don't need six it's not getting
any better
well that is it for group a and Group B
so now let's go back around and take a
look at Kasim Jonna versus Barr Akopian
and it looks like a co pians advantage
has grown these two have played before
but this is their first classical
encounter they have had two draws at the
2017 world rampant championship and and
at the 2017 world blitz championship two
draws total that is yeah I mean
basically when exactly as I said Ben and
I'm surprised that it did because I wish
the lines that I was recommending seemed
to be completely lost for white and it
seems that they followed that night a
six by VAR Queen takes e7 but maybe
there's simply nothing better here like
White's position is that bad already if
we want to make a move here with the
Queen that defends the rook let's
imagine what one that would be well
Queen a to hello night before and pieces
are falling here so I really don't I
don't know what's I don't know what
Kasim Janna was calculating with that
whole sequence of moves earlier that put
his Queen on a 3 because Knight a 6 this
this line is what I mentioned rook e8
and you're covered here there's nothing
that there should be nothing to worry
about he's going for it with that five
but I don't I for one do not believe
this Knight f3 I tell you Ben if this
works this works this is the strangest
forced continuation I've ever seen I
don't believe in this I mean you can
take this you have a what do we have
Queen 4 rook and Bishop here Kasim jonov
is going for the hold on the dark
squares and it's definitely medicine
here and the knight on a six hasn't
joined the action but I don't think
there's any doubt in my mind that this
is 100% winning four bar has taken the
rook and white takes back and now right
the black king is attained 7 I mean
there's no check with the rook there's
Queen checks coming this Knight will
activate itself or it might even stay
there guarding the c7 square while black
sort of arranges his pawns and maybe
gets his King to safety this is dead
lost Kasim jongup's going down here and
believe it or not you know you look at
these two players these aren't two of
the six players in the lead right now so
I know that might be tough to believe
given the legacies
these two men have built over their
careers and they're not done yet any
other games are standing out to you well
the game of Ray Robson and Eric Hanson
has developed quite a bit since last
time all right so everything we can jump
there and just say that on move 33
there's definitely some apparent time
trouble for Hanson but the simplicity of
the position is very remarkable you know
obviously you're not worried about
blundering things when you just have to
make them move so Hanson's not you know
worried about blundering PISA tactic
he's got one full extra pawn here and
he's looking to push for a win whether
he goes in a rook end game or not
remains to be seen he's got this knight
pinned we might see the move King e7
that seems very very normal here you can
always take that Knight later I don't
think there was a rush to do that right
now but if you want it's always there
Bishop takes Knight
so Hansen's in a very comfortable
position he's just played the move king
e7 I think that's a great move how did
we get here I'd love to just run through
this quickly because what an imbalance
that was earlier 94 and we see black
playing just rook e8 and actually white
bailed out with Bishop takes h6 Ray was
not a fan of sitting in this position
with the two bishops disrupting his King
rook d8 coming and all of a sudden like
maybe f5 maybe c5 kicked these Knights
in the center this could be a very very
tough position for Rey so he decides to
bail out with Bishop h6 but of course
this is always going to be in blacks
favor as the most you're going to get
back are two of those three pawns and
that's what he did right here after a
few tactics he was able to get two pawns
back but no more and Erik is is
basically playing for the win here we
got a few more moves King e7 rookie
forecheck and King D 6 so we'll see if
this end game is winning but I think
there are great chances here as you know
basically Erik just has to make five six
more moves get to time control then
evaluate the position with that extra
pawn and I think he has great winning
chances with the black pieces against
Rey Robson and
that all comes from that weird sack we
gave up a full piece and he ended up
with a rook and three pawns for two
minor pieces somehow it paid off for him
in the end
as black is the only one who can win
this game can Rey unpin that night at
all I mean you can't can't you move the
the King away and then like to the file
is it possible well that's the only way
that he's unpinning the knight really
moving the fr moving the e-file if he
goes to the D file he's gonna lose the
knight to c5 and if he you know I don't
know I mean if he goes to the F file yes
you unpin but then I'm probably gonna be
really thinking about taking if I take
you know you can't take with the rook
it's gotta be pawn takes and then all of
a sudden my rook is free to maybe attack
some these other pawns
maybe the King comes up and don't forget
I've got this one extra pawn it's a
passed pawn I can use it as a decoy in
some lines like go take my F pawn I'll
go take your Queen side pawns
I think Rey has a really difficult
defensive task ahead and we see Hansen
doing a very good strategy sometimes you
repeat moves just to gain time before
time control and hit that move forty
mark but this is going to be this is
gonna be a long endgame ahead as Black
is slightly better definitely not
winning only one extra pawn but Black
has the only chances here are you
surprised that none of the games have
ended decisively as of yet right now
today
I guess I'm not necessarily surprised
they they haven't ended yet as all of
the games they although they look crazy
they did look like they were gonna go
for a while so we may see a lot of
decisive results today but they just may
not happen
straightaway as you know at this point
in the tournament players are starting a
tense up and you're not gonna see anyone
just getting absolutely annihilated in
like 20 moves so these players even if
they go down believing it's gonna be a
long struggle like especially this
endgame just as an example if Ray loses
this game it's not gonna be in ten moves
it's not gonna be in 30 minutes I mean
it's gonna take hours of grinding Eric
just played King f6
yes King f6 and I think what he's doing
here he realizes that's a pin right on D
for an absolute pin that's that's gonna
stay there so he's just saying okay I'm
gonna dance around with my King a little
bit he's got up to move 37 once he hits
move 40 then he'll do a real think where
I think at the moment he's just passing
time all right and how about let's see
what else do we have here it looks good
bars pullets and the Adaro we can
revisit that in group B right and we
thought that Nikolas was in trouble the
last time we looked yeah and what's what
has developed since then because what I
see is actually that night only two
missing and that guy was supposed to be
the guy who held the fort together I was
gonna put him on g3 so after this yes
okay it was Bishop takes you to that
makes sense probably the right decision
from Theodore although you're trading
pieces you maintain that dark square
bishop and when you have opposite
colored bishops if you're as long as
you're attacking there's still very good
chances on the board so we have this
position and I have a feeling with a
seven-second the King can slide to h1 or
f1 to get out of this pin probably a
better position for white but man this
is a this is always dangerous to be
dealing with these types of positions
because you get the feeling like there's
some sort of attack that can always be
unleashed as long as there's no e 7
check just imagine Knight f5 at age 4
that that Bishop on g2 pinned by the
rook is starting to feel very
uncomfortable but White's counter play
comes from the fact that in this
position isse evan is a huge threat
there's also rook takes c7 and you know
both of these both of these ideas are
pretty dangerous so Nikolas has got to
take care of them they are on the move
35 and we'll see if time pressure plays
a big role in this game in terms of
players blundering rate of the last
second I want to look at Group A right
now Geoffrey zhong versus liam lee this
is what we said on paper was our key
matchup of the day these two have played
once before and they had a draw same
colors at the 2016 spice cup open at
Webster here in st. Louis and
I know that Jeffrey has that pawn on the
a file what is your assessment since the
last time we saw this game
well definitely I would say positive
developments for Jeffrey the King looks
fairly safe at the moment and the reason
that Bishop eight had to be played was I
thinking
I'm not sure but rook takes c4 I think
we just play I think we just play Bishop
d3
and that seems to work out so he
couldn't quite grab that pawn which
would be tit for tat take my a pawn I'm
not attacking you eat bum he couldn't
quite grab it so you had to play this
move Bishop you ate
now this pawn is hanging there's also
Bishop coming to c6 but at the end of
the day it looks like Geoffrey may just
be escaping with with an extra pawn here
you know the Queen can come back and
don't forget we've got a protected pass
pawn on the a file now it's away from
the action the outside pass pawn I think
that's a very very relevant for for
Geoffrey here not to be not to be
undersold that pawn is very dangerous
White's King remains safe for the moment
and I don't see how blacks pieces
infiltrate that Queen remains offside I
don't see how it Jones the action and
less taking on e4 but if white can deal
with that I'm worried that this Queen
just never gets in the action for
example in this position Ben where's his
Queen go I mean it has to go to like a
eight or something after moving the
bishop or it has to go to h6 and play g5
but that's that's just crazy with your
king there so I think that Queen on g6
may be a real issue here because we have
a situation where I've got a queen stuck
on the Kings side and I've got a pawn
ready to run on the Queen side that
seems like a bad combination
maybe that a pawn will be very hard to
stop but trying to figure out how to
defend his pawn here is Geoffrey Zhang
they have hit move forward though some
time pressure not an issue in this game
is this this is a game we definitely
expect to go on another game of note in
group a vastly evanka versus Benjamin
Bach there has been a pawn promoted
Yvonne shuck has just promoted a pawn
but don't let that headline flee because
I think he's in trouble the rook has
just taken that and oh we have a result
actually on another board actually Group
B Andre bars pullets and Nicholas
theodoro
Baris pullets as we thought came out
victorious and they are signing the
score sheets
right now that game that game did look
like it was about to I don't know if I
could say about to finish because I
think Nicholas must have missed
something in calculation there but it
did look like the movie se7en Shack as I
pointed out was very very difficult to
deal with so yeah this this result
doesn't surprise me but I didn't think
it would come that quickly then yeah
right
the seems like he just he just let me
seven check happen and maybe just miss
that in the corner Queen a eight check
just puts him away there's there's no
way to cover his back rank yeah for sure
and I think we should get angry boorish
Beau it's down here
the former the champion great guy though
have you have you known Andrey before
this event no and I haven't haven't had
much of a chance to speak with him so
it'd actually be great to get him down
in the studio if he wants to talk about
his nice win here as he puts away
Nicolas theodoro and definitely improves
his tournament so far let's look over at
group B's Gregory cut down on versus
Sergei Arenberg they are about four
moves away from time control and they
are both in trouble
well what about that game that we didn't
quite catch because the Yvonne check
ball came it looked like Sharon was was
gonna lose that potentially like Yvonne
check here is basically I think he's
getting mated like Queen age one is
checkmate for example is Brooke f6 does
he have time to deal with this I have a
feeling that someone's getting made it
here so rook f6 has to be played yeah
it's on the board someone's cut
someone's getting mated here if work
check King g7 Queen g8 King h6 where's
the meat because otherwise is white
who's getting checkmated on each one
this is this looks very intense remember
Bach has been playing on increment this
whole time and Yvonne shook suddenly he
went kind of crazy he moved his F pawn
and he exposed his King a little bit but
in exchange is actually both players
Kings completely out in the open
offhand though this doesn't look like
White has a continuation if I check
King g7 Queen g8 King h6 I don't have
another move and this is checkmate in
one and my queen is hanging so that
can't be it if rook g8 King h6 if I take
here then just rook takes back and again
there's mates everywhere and if I take
here that's checkmate in one this
doesn't look good for you von Schuch has
this move rook f6 kind of a desperado
just throwing itself to the defense of
the black King but it may actually be
just a winning move as down to fourteen
seconds is Yvonne Chuck that variation
one of the variations you showed there I
wonder if the White Queen taking the
rook on g6 is a computer move to to
disable the mate but [ __ ] you I mean
white is just right here you just take
with the rook though and if you check
King up check again King up again
there's just no checks remember what I
said earlier in this game but how this
Queen on b3 was not in the action that's
been true the whole game been that Queen
hasn't done anything I mean it exerts
pressure on this diagonal but look at
how black's pieces are just swarming the
white king I think he von Schuch is is
dead lasse he must be made it here he's
gonna throw in some checks but with his
time taking down five seconds I mean we
got to see him move from him I wonder if
we can get a shot of the players and see
see what their status is here I mean
even shook maybe I don't know if he's
losing on time or if he's you did it oh
man with three seconds I think he threw
that check in rook e8 played on the
board
King g7 Queen g8 King h6 but now I think
he's faced with a position that is
losing rook e1 only move rook e1 must be
the move here you cover me at or sorry I
should say that's not necessarily maid
anymore but it's mating - I think that's
gotta be played here well we might want
to keep a look at this game I understand
that we do have Andre boorish bullets
ready to come in for an interview so I
will bow out and we'll get Andre in here
absolutely that sounds fantastic
that game just finished as you saw but
this one is really heating up here
reason that it's just gonna slow down
though is because they have just hit
time control as facility von Schuch
somehow you know crawls to the 40th move
and he does finally make time control
will he survive this position though I
don't know it almost looks like made on
the board
rookie one appears to be may be
necessary to to cover the checkmate
there with Queen h1 what can happen
after this all of a sudden it's you know
now it's just rough g6 yeah rook g6
there's no check on f8 that's the issue
here well guys this might be this might
be a win for Benjamin Bach I mean Vasily
even shake is going to think about this
as they've hit time control but I think
Bach hitting the Queen threatening me is
going to win this game because rookie
one is the only move that I see here to
actually stop this to stop this idea
from happening maybe we see some crazy
move like rookie 5 trying to hit this
square so that after check King G for
Queen age 5 something like that it's
really hard I mean Brooke g6 is there in
every case so I have a feeling that even
trick might just be lost here they've
hit time control and we're sitting in
this position here but with Queen h1
check and Queen age 5 on the board as
well as rook g6 threatening the Queen
and the pawn so if rook e1 rook g6 seems
to put the game away for for Benjamin
box so we'll have to see what happens
there but in the meantime we're actually
joined for an interview by Andre
bargepole it's joining us a city welcome
thank you and we just came off a win we
we watched the conclusion of this one
against theodoro although I have to say
it always feels pretty scary when you
win some material or you went upon but
in these Kings Indian positions you know
you can always maybe just get made it
out of nowhere so yeah did you did you
feel like it was clean the whole way or
you were unsure at some point of course
it was very tense so I mean I could have
filmed that I was better especially it
was bona fide
right but still as you said like in the
Indians
quite as much better but right there's
always those tricks and the yeah after
he played something like Ruby g4 right
near the end of the game so I was really
unsure of like where it goes I just get
the feeling that they should be still
winning for a void but mm-hmm
well why don't we just jump through the
game from the start maybe we can skip to
the important points and just give us
your thoughts about how the the opening
winds and maybe the middle game
especially when when you had to give up
your dark square bishop felt like if
things got interesting yes
see father's already removed replied to
right here yeah yeah and in this idea 19
I think this looks interesting so there
are some lines like was nigh 27 this one
yeah so yeah but anyway
position is something something between
like Kings Indian and green fix and
actually I I didn't expect might exist
except like some kind of [ __ ] I just
also looks playable yeah I did 64 mm-hm
I believe we played rookie 196 yeah and
I kind of feeling that this position
should be better because when I played
this post for white and black and still
I mean objectively should be better but
of course that country chances yeah
always
yeah b3 looks interesting so I thought
one bit to my bishop is yeah you're
makes it harder for black to play I know
so I could Bishop e3 like Bishop d7 you
should be to Queen seven okay so yeah
it's difficult to say like if told us
moose or necessary or not for sure both
sides but I mean just the game so
logical yeah he played 94 so I thought
that this is the most concrete approach
because if I play let's say 91 like the
other idea just to transfer my knight
somewhere to c4 maybe
so then b6 and I don't have 93
immediately right so because he first
came in so I need to spend some some
extra temple at Queen c2 but that I
wasn't sure if it's
yeah because I mean I'm just you know
kind of wasting sometimes so 94 was more
concrete so and I'm just attacking right
away so b6 and Bishop e3 and now right I
just have a threat of Knight b6 so yeah
that's why he he has to make some
important decisions there's a take on e4
but then I saw that position it just
looks shitty game so yeah not before
probably the best movie actually I
didn't experiment before I took like
just I take the pawn and I'm just torn
up but right but actually turned out to
be not that easy for me so giving away
dark square bishop is always always a
decision yeah but but still I mean he
hasn't created any country play yet so I
felt like I just should be just pawn up
but then okay 205 G takes us five yeah
he turned out that actually my queen is
misplaced in before so I'd better do
something about it but if I play Queen
d2 let's say right away so then probably
he has Bishop takes a four and I thought
that here probably he has good
compensation right just just
positionally so he would write like
maybe four maybe transfer night to see
if I so he's got some options so yeah a
coupon you have is sitting on a four
here's its yeah that's why I played nice
III met Ron I thought like if he plays
directly efore then I always have Knight
d4
yeah and still I have some good chances
like 92 94 but what he can do it wasn't
you can't play it for obviously because
he points falling here yeah so but he
played the rook of seven I think that
was a good decision of him because here
he's kind of threatening sometimes to
play Bishop of fate even so for example
I played
92 was obvious ad and I see four then
Bishop a fake right yeah this place yeah
yeah so that's why I spent some time and
I thought like either the play Queen h4
instead of 92 yeah here Queen h4 but I
wasn't sure if my queen is
it's a better place h5 yeah Bishop a
bishop of six between age five and and
here I wasn't sure if if if it's a good
score for Queen so fresh still probably
I mean the best plan for me is just to
play ninety two and twenty two back
right so and then bring Knight to c4 at
some point so because of all that I
decide to play ninety-two just so you
know just like have like a freeway
yes safer way back so and I could have
film that if I if I regroup somehow so
then like a long term is just to trade
this night on this section
yeah and to convert this pawn in 94 yeah
he just kind of trying to mess things up
yeah Prince before and obviously it's
it's not that easy to play for black
because I mean there is no like direct
plan so yeah there's nothing in media so
just just to wait you know for this
opportunity to push Italy for F Queen's
right yeah and here rookie do one maybe
not the best move so after I played it
like an in a couple of moves I realized
that probably the rook CD one was better
yeah because I have my rook only one
clearly better place than on c1 right
actually I'm not pressing on c7 anymore
so he defended yeah I don't maybe don't
need it there yeah look you wanna know
so I can bring my queen we see one so
for example Quincy one and then I see
three and I just play normally let's say
yeah yeah because I like my queen on
this day I don't see 186 because
sometimes I can have Knight g5 for
exampleif or right then maybe even a g5
that was good so page six fish for so
yeah so yeah that's why probably this
was flattened across its true key d1
right
but another on the other hand I just
didn't see like what to do so I needed
to protect this deep deep on somewhere
who's the rookie do you want yeah 96
yeah here couldn't before
here I realize that probably Queen
before going back is actually in this
setup not that bad because Queen c2 I
didn't like because of Bishop h6 at some
point so for example maybe right away
Bishop h6
say Ruby one and probably why it still
is better but but here maybe comes lucky
for III or if or F for yeah well this is
the type of position where you almost
wish the rocket yeah one piece misplaced
and and actually the black has all the
pieces efficient compensation so yeah
that's why Quinn before looks correct
one again probably I'm not sure how you
say hard to say because yeah I'm sure
it's very subtle differences yeah
so here he played that foreign the I
don't know otherwise if he doesn't play
a four still not what he can do so if
you think that this was sort of the
right moment for him to whether it's the
right move or not just just go for it
with with that for did this move
surprise you I mean obviously I thought
that he just desperately needs to find
some push like a four or yeah every for
basically that's it if he doesn't do
this sooner or later I just play the
Queen D 293 yeah and then slowly like
might be Queen e2 92 94 and that's an
exactly before you do so right plays a
for right in the moment when I don't
have control over if Foursquare so I
pretty much have to take on a four so if
I had like knight on c3 so probably I
could play 94 so like in some previous
that was the idea yeah yeah so I pretty
much have to take on the for and Bishop
g4 I thought the best move so and that's
why I mean that's how he shows me that
my rook should be only one
yeah heroes I still kinda feelin that
this should be was large advantage for
white but obviously it became very I'm
not sure about t4 I don't know I thought
maybe he can yeah maybe he could take
Bishop of three
Bishop takes a three and here we go h4
I'm just kind of try trying to do
something positionally so I'm not sure
if it's because good enough for black
yeah yeah looks online because I mean
again like he's not on the 66 is
excellent so pretty much all the pieces
if I play Queen d2 then maybe Bishop h6
is the possibilities in the shade
transferring rooks - yeah actually I was
more afraid of this okay play d4 Knight
g5 I mean optically it looks completely
winning for white but then yeah so 996
sure for sure yeah play this so he takes
the six oh yeah if I take 94 the new
page six yeah still take yet Bishop a to
the best move F of 10 I gets to g3 it's
probably yeah yeah I'm here after I just
realized of maybe I mean I got their own
impression that I was right like somehow
he can just sit in this position and you
know actually like I still have this
pawn on e6
which is very annoying to him so he's
not this pawn probably he he would have
sufficient compensation but here he he
needs to spend a lot of time to grab
this pawn yes and I was surprised
watching at really how quickly the game
finished from here because I thought
that black had sort of established that
okay he might be might be worse but at
least maybe he can try to play on with
opposite bishops and control with dark
squares but the game actually finished
really quickly from here because for
example I had the interesting idea like
to play f4 here which seems really cool
but but I didn't like c4 c5 and then he
he brings his Bishop 24 and now he has
really good control play because he just
can positionally play Queen f6 taken a6
and Bishop on d4 it's probably not worth
oh yeah this looks like
but still I mean maybe I'm wrong maybe
also yeah but I mean yeah just
practically I didn't want to go for it
so yeah we did too I mean I didn't see
anything here Quinn of six I was a
little surprised by the small so I I
calculated only finish for pipe like
yeah yeah I mean it seemed more natural
because now he has Queen h3 also Bishop
h6 and on young Queenie I'd say the same
I get nearly five because actually it
was remarkable but this is this threat
like the game was somehow really
difficult to deal with
yeah but I thought that he has something
but now I just cannot recall them Quinn
chief work in the phone industry when
you want your bishops III but then I
just sacrificed back rooks its requisite
dreams a good move because otherwise if
I click windy too then surprisingly if
you can play 21:21 Queen c3 yeah and if
rook d2 then maybe he has some
connection yeah so here's like one more
precise yeah Queen here so he doesn't
have this rigid to but maybe he has
something a crew chief I for sure
something I just couldn't recall like
what they didn't like maybe Ruby g5
actually and your effect like we need
then Bishop of faith mmm-hmm and this
it's not quite working because I guess
he always has some rook takes right rook
takes G to move yeah but probably Oh
actually yeah here here what I cook a
rookie for I mean I was really yeah it
looks great yeah because if he takes
Queenie for just the Queen g5 if he
begins with rook G 294 doesn't work
because of right yeah that's a good
seven seven year if you take some g2
instead of taken only for and I seem to
take in g2 and Queenie for nothing
that and then I just go clean and game
from Luke's asylum yeah yes yep it was
this line because yeah if they see that
I can take one only for without any
compensation then right it should be
winning but Quinn of six yeah maybe this
is this is a pretty strong continuation
just once the Queen gets on T 5 this
thread is yeah but Coakley correctly all
of that so age three yeah I didn't like
Bishop h6 so that's why I spent like
almost all the time yeah at this point
so but but they just didn't see anything
better than h3 so if I play for example
with LePage 325 immediately then queen
g6 and discovering this yeah covering
the square and if Queen eight and ninety
eight so that's very important because
it's kind of protecting the dates Frank
cousin who's 98 and I'm right I cannot
defend the g2 so and some oh yeah maybe
I mean I just simply mister three
because
somehow hold a slightly yeah well the
thing I mean if I called my exactly well
yeah maybe just mister three here yeah
but then after 25 I mean like in photo
page three like in this position 25
right instead of this yeah because well
yeah it's really frustrating because all
the all the ways don't don't seem to
work there's no way to just get the King
out or yeah well it still still ended up
finishing very quick yeah yeah six and I
believe that kind of strong move 23
because if act like Wendy 5 here then he
can just take on g2 let's say in g2 and
might not be that great in g1 because we
always have usually you can rely on e7
to work so like you said one Queen takes
dislike somebody exactly yeah that's
kind of so you were probably surprised
than by g6 because yeah it's your life
doesn't have this idea was Queen g6
anymore so and Bishop h6 Queen C 3 that
was kind of focus a critical line
because now he has something like Ruby G
to change the queen is 3 but but then
again I'm just ending up I mean not not
this 106 well yeah yeah no so that that
line was was critical ya know who knows
that this point just felt like this
should be but but now I mean if you go
back x3 Ruby 6 oh no keep logistics
right on page 6 25 years
there's no time for frequency six right
yeah right yeah here 25 4 actually yeah
yeah here I was very positive about it I
think you should be at this point yeah
but but here I thought the Ruby g5 was
kind of the only move right yeah he was
also in some time pressure is mutual
yeah like maybe three minutes left
yeah because we I think I was looking at
this position and then either you give
this mate or he gives this me yes
obviously it's just work so the ponds
covering and everything is it's working
here so I mean this is a tense tense
game you mentioned it got a lot scarier
than maybe you thought but in the end
somehow you worked out the calculator
that was kind of scary yeah usually
usually it's like in mikeen so what to
do yeah but a win is a great result and
I mean thanks for coming down to the
studio and sharing your thoughts and
really appreciate it good luck in the
rest of the tournament thank you thank
you that's Andre bars bullets and he's
very nice win against Nikolas state over
there in the B group and that is the I
mean there's a few more decisive games
in the B group as well that that just
got announced I think we saw Dennis CAD
rich won his game which I was expecting
from earlier that that position for
Stein Grimson was not promising and we
see a forced mating that there on that
board also we had circuit Ehrenburg with
the to Bishop position against kadanoff
and I mentioned earlier in that one as
well that I was expecting a victory from
from Sergey so in the B group I think
things are more or less as expected and
the game between korilla and Mistah is
still ongoing but a big advantage there
to alexander Mistah and the B group
which is the remaining game there all
right Aman did you did you say that
Jeffrey Zhang beat lammle I didn't see
that no I was in the a I was in the B
group I was in the dunk mentality all
right let's see how that game ended if
you don't mind because this is the
potentially a really big result I mean
I've seen we have the three big
showdowns in Group A and Jeffrey Zhang
looking to break through we sawed around
here and I was mentioning that this a
pawn is running black cannot take that
pawn it's got his Queen trapped I think
all things in favor of Jeffrey's
position and simply a for Benny I mean
he's just gonna run that pawn so what
ended up happening is look Wang Lee and
his queen just can't get out it's just
such a problem here it's trapped in jail
on the Kings side and it means that just
probably an easy conversion here for
Geoffrey who had to be a little careful
on the light squares but that King
position on h7 is not gonna stay safe
forever as rook f8 rook h8 is in the
position and just look at this
domination Queen here where is the Queen
going Queen d8 you don't even have g5 I
mean this is just like the worst kind of
looks wanting to be put in you almost
have nothing to do queen g6 rook f8 and
just a meeting pattern there if King f5
where is he planning to go probably
something like rook to f8 or actually
rook takes h5 is maybe just even nicer
and that's a nice checkmate there g5 and
take that so that's what he was planning
there and maquon basically didn't have
any choice because his Queen was stock
the whole game it was just no way out of
that so Geoffrey Jean with the white
pieces claims a win against the top seed
in the a group you know we are just 13
days away from round 1 of the 2019 US
Championship and Geoffrey Zhang has he's
no stranger to the US Championship and
he's won the US Junior before anyone the
world junior before but I can't help but
thinking that Geoffrey Zhang might be
one of the Dark Horse's this year I feel
like he always is you know he's he's
always dangerous in those those US
Championships and I think the best sign
for him
that very clearly he's in good form and
you can always have an e low that you
measure people by but forum is another
thing that can be temporary and right
now he seems to be playing very well so
he looks to maybe keep that momentum
going forward you have the big three you
have Wesley so Hikaru Nakamura Fabiana
Carolina
you could add linear Domingues in there
now big four but Sam Shanklin won it
last year and no one really thought he
would write Jeffrey Zhang someone to
watch maybe we talked to Sam I remember
last year at this very event the spring
chess classic yeah and Sam was on here
promoting his book and we were like well
good luck in the championship and no one
really thought he would do it Jeffrey
might be that guy this year he could
very well be he could very well be I see
the other big results in the a group was
Benjamin Bach did the Yvan shook from
that position that I was looking at
right before our interview with barge
poets and yeah basically he just
resigned on the spot after hitting move
40 because once again there's only one
way that I see to stop Queen H was two
ways Queen H 1 and Queen H five is
meeting two rookie five stops the Queen
from reaching age five but again after
this there's just rook g6 winning the
Queen and the other way of doing it was
after King h6 rook e1 stopping Queen h1
but then roof g6 wins once again because
of checkmate or the Queen's so nice you
know kind of comeback victory from Bach
I'm not sure how his position was
earlier it looked a little loose but at
the same time he went for a g5 and he
was attacking Vasily the whole game and
it's funny Evon shook and laQuan the M
both went down in their games because of
a queen that was like way offside and
just couldn't seem to join the action so
funny a similar theme today as Benjamin
Bach and Jeffrey Zhang both picked up
some huge wins in the EA group right
right let's take a look at our standings
so far in Group A after six and a half
rounds more than five and a half I guess
technically and we see that Jeffrey
Zhang right now temporarily clear first
but we had those three games between all
six leaders standing at three points
where do you think we'll be at whenever
this day is done Amman well it
definitely looks not looks like but a
Cobian is
so he's gonna jump up to three points
that means that Kasim jahnava stays way
at the bottom of the tournament at just
one and a half I think that we have a
very good chance for nanak and atari to
draw their game and which looks like a
pretty equal end game right now but
definitely still ongoing I think the
question is whether or not Eric Hanson
is going to convert his one extra pawn
rook hand game against Ray Robson if he
can he's gonna join the leader and be
the co-leader with Geoffrey Zhong up
there at four points so I think that's
the only question mark as I think Kobe
ins gonna win Nash neck and tie are you
probably gonna draw and Ken Hansen win
to join the leaders and let's take a
look at our B group result our standings
rather and there's only one game left
and it's still the by ginchy show but
it's not an absolute runaway right I
mean he could be caught oh absolutely no
this I don't think anyone feels like he
can't be caught he just needs one bad
game right and then and then suddenly uh
anyone can catch him the game that's
still ongoing I would say is really
likely going to be Alexander Mesa
winning that one so that would mean that
he jumps up to three and a half points
and jumps into third position there
Alexei Sorokin we remember he was
actually oh and two to start off this
tournament now he's up there in third
place that is a full flip of the
tournament so he is kind of back on the
horse Andriy barge poles we had him in
for an interview he had a nice win today
and he is way up there at four points so
he's gaming reel chase to by Jin she and
bhaijan she still has you know some
tough opponents to go so he will be on
everybody's radar trying to catch up to
him
indeed you will be well of course we're
gonna be back here tomorrow for round
number seven and the games began at 1:00
p.m. Central time at us chess champs
calm remember though we're on the air
with you two and a half hours later at
3:30 p.m. Central
but tonight the action continues here on
the st. Louis Chess Club YouTube channel
if you're on facebook go to the youtube
channel at 6:30 p.m.
Caleb Dendy steps in to host viewers
Choice submitted by viewer
like you to our email address that we
give out during the class we can't give
it out to everybody though because we'll
just get inundated by bad games if you
want it you've got a search for it he'll
be looking at your games from 6:30 to
7:30 and then at 7:30 a special edition
of checkmating it's just in the Romantic
era with our substitute for this evening
national master Jim McLaughlin who
usually teaches Tuesday nights tactics
time class and occasionally chess
openings explain so you'll be seeing
those tonight and then I understand we
might have a third hour for you at 8:30
p.m. right back Christel we might I
don't know yeah there we might have an
edition of ladies play the people and
you never know who you're gonna see
unlaid ease play the people this is the
second episode Wow they're probably the
best episode so that's all we have to
say about that tomorrow we will see you
once again but until then for the entire
B team today including Ryan Chester
Tammy hi Danni Machuca Isaac's Ron's my
name is Ben Simon he's the chest by
Grandmaster Aman Hamilton with the
awesome hair and we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you